when i read
the um kurzweil's book about the
singularity
to me it read just like um religious
language like it read like you know
because he
in fact it's so much like revelation to
me
when i read it that i even assign it to
my students in my classes i'm like
this is this is it you know this is like
a really great book
of the singularity you know the coming
singularity and um
this religious event because it seems
like it when he writes about it he says
i felt it before i even understood it
you know
he i mean kurzweil kurzweil yeah what i
mean what are your
feelings about my feelings thoughts
feelings too about
the idea of the singularity do you think
it's ultimately the thing that echoes
throughout the history of ideas
is this um like
moment of revelation like this
this almost mythological religious
moment
or is there something uh more
physical to this idea of concrete
concrete
about the idea of um there'll come a
point where our technology there'll be
like a phase shift between
uh the the basic fabric of
like humanity of how we interact you
know how evolution brought us to be
this biological interaction that our
technology
uh crosses some kind of line of
capability
that the world be more technology
than human to where it will leave us
behind
so oh yeah i don't think it's going to
leave us behind i think it's going to
take us along
but it will be i mean i guess the idea
of the singularity first of all isn't
the idea of the singularity is like we
can't possibly predict what's on the
other side of the singularity
the sense is like this is like the world
will be fundamentally transformed
yes i okay so right and then it was you
know
um this was characterized in various
movies like lucy and stuff like that
uh you know lucy being the first human
that right we so kind of
replicating and this is going to be the
next iteration of humans
is the singularity um i actually don't
believe that
um frankly however and the reason i
don't believe it is because we're
material beings
and technology has to have a host so
we're not going to you know
become something super abstract like
there's it's just
impossible to do there's nothing like
that well people would be listening to
this podcast a hundred years from now
and laughing at it because
they'll be all existing in a virtual
reality we'll be all information
uh as opposed to material meaning
connected to some kind of
concept of physical uh physical reality
i don't even know the right words to use
you see that's because there are none
because there's no place from there's no
view from nowhere
there's no non-material
like we have thoughts but they're
connected to us
right they're in our you know they're
somehow okay
as far as uh as far as you know listen
platonic forms i think is
about as as you know close to what we're
talking about as
possible like this place where these
things exist
and then there's like a physical
instantiation of it nope
uh the question is from the perspective
of the platonic
form what does our physical world look
like
you know what i'm saying like uh you
know if if say you're a creature
existing in a virtual reality like
if you grew up your whole life
in a virtual reality game like what is
it
and somebody in that virtual reality
world tells you
that there actually exists this physical
world
and in fact your own you
think you're in this virtual world but
it's actually you're in a body
and this is just your mind putting
yourself and there's a piece of
technology
like how will they how would they be
able to
think of that physical world would they
would they sound exactly like you just
sounded a minute ago saying like
well that's silly who cares if there's a
physical world
it's the the entirety of the perception
and my memories and all of that
is in this other realm of um
of like information it's just all just
information i
why do i need some kind of weird meat
bag
to contain so there's a great again i
always
you know return to something for your
audience to read or you
um there's a great very short article
online for free by david chalmers do you
know him
he's the philosopher of consciousness
yeah he interviewed him on this podcast
yeah
yeah yeah he's cool um
[Music]
i used to i was friends with his best
friend for a while when
in when i was in grad school um he
probably has some weird friends he does
he's a philosopher okay so um
i like his fashion choice and hairstyle
time
to hang out with him a little bit he's a
great guy okay
so he wrote this article which i use a
lot i love it because it's
accessible to undergraduates and it's
called matrix as metaphysics
and basically it's it's an answer to
external world skepticism
which is basically how do we know
there's an external world
right how do we know that we're not in a
matrix right now and so
um basically he's using he's he's
also he even references he uses a
religious reference even he says
you could think of the matrix of the
movie as
a new as the new um book of genesis
for our new world right and i thought
yeah that's absolutely correct
because you know we don't know
and we don't we won't know for sure or
for certain
therefore what we know is what is real
to us
and so he goes through these scenarios
and within
philosophy it's called there's a this is
different from that but it's like this
brain in a vat
right if you're a brain in a vat and
some
not so kind scientist is like recreating
this world for you just to see
you know and you think you're this
awesome rock star
right and you're living this awesome
existence but you're actually just this
brain
in this vat okay but there's still a
brain in a vat
okay so his idea in um
the matrix says metaphysics kind of
takes out the brain in a vat like this
ex
i don't know if this is possible so i've
read critiques of this
that you know what you're talking about
is a non-dualism like there's like
um you know or
it's not necessarily a non-dualism um
i just i mean information in and of
itself
has to have some kind of material
component to it
i mean it's that that that uh when taken
outside the realm of human beings
because
dualism is kind of talking about humans
yeah in a sense
it's just possible to me that there
could be creatures that exist
in a very different form perhaps rely on
very different set of materials
yes that that may perhaps not even
look like materials to us yes i agree
which is why like
information it could be even in
computers
the information that's traveling inside
a computer
is connected to actual uh
material movement right right so like
there is it is ultimately connected to
material movement but it's less and less
about the material and more and more
about the information
so i i just mean that there's it's
possible that uh you think the
singularity is basically
like sloughing off our material
existence
well i don't know because i can tell you
that this has been the hope of
philosophers and
theologians forever yeah well i don't i
i think we're living in this thing
through a singularity i i don't think i
think this world
just just like as you've said already um
has been already transformed
significantly and keeps continually
being transformed yes
and we're just riding this yeah we are
big beautiful wave
of uh transformation and uh
that's why it's both exciting and
terrifying
uh from a scientific perspective that
like
we're so bad at predicting the future
and the future is always so
amazing in terms of the the things it
has brought us
i mean i don't know if it's always will
be this exciting in terms of the rate of
innovation
but it seems to be increasing still and
it's really exciting it's it's exciting
yeah it's terrifying because obviously
we're building better and better tools
for destroying ourselves but
i on the optimistic side believe that we
also
can build better and better tools to uh
defend against
all the ways we could destroy ourselves
and it's kind of this interesting race
of innovation yeah
you